hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
tell them your name
Lauren Francesca Lauren Francesca who's
been on this channel many at times is
back here today we were gonna watch a
video from one of my favorite YouTube
channels it does these great list videos
these wonderful British guys chance
called what culture they're video ten
movies that changed because of actors
bad behavior I was in a short film with
Lauren something that you wrote yeah
starting I can vouch that she has
terrible behavior onset if there's any
like producers Rutgers casting directors
who are watching this video stop it
total chaos to work with major diva
everything was being rewritten because
it didn't make her look good enough she
can relate with this video Lauren I got
your promos down don't work I'm not no
no people in love honest she's not like
that at all I wouldn't say that to her
face if she was just behind her back
thank you Greg Greg all the stuff
you would think that film studios rabba
short fuse when actors refused to do as
they're told or simply turn up feeding
obviously a famous game where big books
are showered on big talent and the
interest of making big profit if you
were clearly working with Simon
gradients you would throw them out as
nobody likes a rotten egg but sometimes
Studios and filmmakers have shown
remarkable patience with their
misbehaving actors how many times have
passionate situations on set boil over
into a point babban on sad sets like
when lawrence journey and Quentin
Tarantino came to blows without anyone
getting sacked
it's just counted as a bit of a blip and
everyone dust themselves off and gets on
with it not always though sometimes
actors do something so bad on set that
the whole movie is changed to
accommodate them presumably because
firing them would have just been too
easy in that case then I am the office
brawler ash from what cultures new start
up boxing division and these are 10
movies that change because of actors bad
behavior 10 Wesley Snipes is blade 22
I've heard a lot about this one bill
troll guru story of Wesley Snipes his
time on blade Trinity will live long in
infamy
well after everyone has forgotten how
much of a disappointing there's that
movie was thanks to the testimony of
co-star Patton Oswalt sipes was
non-compliant throughout the production
and his integration was very helped by
his insistence on staying in character
for the entire shoot presumably Osiris
meant that approach I think I played as
being rather casual about his work
schedule - it's also revealed that its
absence fundamentally changed the moving
in his words a lot of the lines of Ryan
Reynolds has which is a result of Wesley
not being there after all the crowning
act of defiance by the former that
necessitated a freedom change to the
film and post-production looking
refusing to open his eyes for one scene
and I'm having to be superimposed onto
his eyelids ink
nine crispy I wouldn't read his wines in
Chinese angels you know more whose
apparent difficult nasaan movie sets and
brews acting achievements that's
probably unfair because in his words all
he did to get quiet from Back to the
Future 2 and replaced with the Sun did
ask a few questions nobody wanted him to
ask what mode Styx
anyway decided that the script was so
awful that he simply wouldn't
participate in saying any of them home
is a version the exposition had be
nonsense who's been charged with saying
costing him his job again it just made
for a huge change in his character they
brought him back to the signal simply
became a mute interesting detail all him
in the entire film will often tell you
that the biggest issue with the island
of dr. Moreau was Marlon Brando Brando
strange performance choices and
characterization demands his experience
and his dream project got off the ground
replacing Bruce Willis when he had
expectedly dropped out film uh started
bold demanding his filming schedule was
shortened then when production was
halted because of a tragedy in Brando's
life he swapped his role entirely to an
easy one and then he was reportedly rude
and abrasive and would sit on the floor
and refused
suggestions to change the seven channing
tatum's dancing changed and achieve this
is the NC way behind them by being
consciously more edgy in fact I know
broccoli has made something of an artist
a little most those would be in The
Bling Ring but the same year that film
came out she was also almost a
surprisingly dark movie they're called
were to be pretty wholesome as part of
the joke since she'd be thrust into a
boys club space essentially surprising
human presented whether this is the gang
script she accepted it without issue
having legitimately read it and watching
for herb so did Channing Tatum when
presented with the opportunity to play a
leather clad dog but she was supposed to
share a scene around the point where
Tatum's secret role was revealed but
Watson walked off the scene because but
had jamie foxx gotten what he was told
the end of 2006 is Miami Vice would have
definitely been different that it might
have also cost him his health or his
life is also a key consideration your
own issued some sequences are filmed in
the Dominican Republic and one area is
apparently so dangerous that it was
deemed a no-go area by the local police
it didn't stop the filmmakers though and
they simply recruited the local gang
members to protect them somewhat
unsurprisingly the circumstances led to
a police officer being shocked
so what any Fox walked upset and refused
to film outside good for him it's not
bad maybe smart is the wind so it didn't
help his image it also led to Michael
mind having to regen his plans to shoot
the finale in Paraguay and it was all
shot in Miami instead
which sort of makes sense what would the
trifling or by Patrick Stewart roasted
Star Trek insurrection script and it
changed okay there are some things you'd
probably pay attention to if you're
working on a film script Kristen Bell
bellowing insults at you and questioning
your intellect would probably stink
ranking highest of all has to be the
polite but devastating letter penned by
Sir Patrick Stewart battle face Star
Trek writer Michael piller who was hired
to write insurrection having already
written for the next generation
unfortunately for him experienced
counted four little answers I'm captain
sent him a letter ripping it to pieces
now loosen your belt for this absolute
spanking as I quote it has no surprises
it has no scale it has a little humor
and what it has is cliched and tired it
has no romance
it is not sexy it breaks no new ground
it owns a user podcast it has little fun
it is done I have taken detailed notes
on the story but we might feel there is
so little for us here to even start work
on I am very sorry my reactions are so
negative but they are so because my
hopes to make this a super film are so
high if it was anyone else you camp out
as impertinent it's an invitation to
rewrite the entire plot somehow the dual
Monson's that resulted was signed off on
as good enough this time around Oh Ben
Affleck's fandom changed gone girl part
of the whole acting thing is doing
things you wouldn't normally do Vin
Diesel for instance it's not a big tree
Daniel day-lewis was not a butcher Tom
Cruise is not a murderous assassin
probably buckle down athlete one
requirement for his role in gone girl
proved to be so much for sticking points
that his stubbornness shut down
production for four days and it was all
down to a hat the film called reflects
character to hide his identity in New
York for a brief scene by wearing a
Yankees cap you can say what you
Worthington but he knows how to protect
himself from making disastrous career
choices oh wait actually no sorry that
is not entirely true is it it can't be
given his career trajectory after avatar
anyway maybe it is still fair to say he
can identify potentially damaging career
choices and trying to injure a co-star
that he didn't want to be upstaged by my
sake until you realize that the co-star
was a mechanical all named buboes in the
original the Duesenberg
played a fairly key role offering comic
relief but in the remake here's where I
go to you to a 15-second cameo that we
are all very angry about so what yes
well Worthington apparently hated Bubo
so much according to director Louis
Leterrier that he kept threatening it
with physical violence and trying to
damage it a little bit to make it
unusable what in the end his hooliganism
paid off and the director agreed to come
out because of it to fade in a way
refused to shoot a new ending Oh won't
fade down always kinda has reputation
because fighting away spotlight refusal
to do as she was told actually came
after the completion of the movie and
sabotage plans to change the ending to
the directors new requirements after
years of being reportedly difficult to
work with
bill away appeared in tepid thriller the
temp in 1993 opposite Laura Flynn Boyle
and Timothy Hutton it wasn't good and
she ended up winning the Razzie so you
can probably forgive her wanting to get
out of the way as quickly as possible
unfortunately for director Tom Holland
that meant his change of heart on the
original ending different time loss yes
Boyle and masters tequila to switch a
character in as the real killer couldn't
be done according to a book when the
suggestion came up out of the
realization that the film didn't work as
it had been shaft Dunaway simply stopped
taking the studio's calls until they
agreed with her and she remained a
victim in the other new ending that they
shot
so basically digging your heels in one
Marlon Brando hated Apocalypse Now so he
sabotaged poster boy but onset
misbehavior thanks to a couple of
notorious movies and his apparent
reluctance to anything that we in any
way compromised Marlins brand that isn't
it anyway on Apocalypse Now Brando was
very much only one ingredient in a big
disaster a suit that should have never
ended up being a finished film let alone
a great one yet it remains so it's crazy
that it's what most people talk about
Brando couldn't memorize his lines which
was one thing but he also knew Toria
Slee turned off massively over white so
Francis Ford Coppola had to dress him in
black by the shadow and shoot mostly
just his face there's some debate over
how much Brando was misbehaving and how
much his reputation was unfairly
attributed as such in hindsight because
his disruption of the shoot and refusal
to stick to a schedule actually also led
to him rewriting a good deal of the
script and it's not like it's a bad
script or a bad film in the end so maybe
you take the rough with the smooth
showed up massively over very good lord
scroll subscribe that's why I like this
channel is a good channel the thing they
brought about Brando Ryan Gosling was
cast in a movie called The Lovely Bones
directed by Lord of the Rings as Peter
Jackson Gosling put out in like 30
pounds good role there's like photos of
him on like a red carpet or somebody
showing he gained too much away Peter
Jackson was like what you do you're
fired
they got Mark Wahlberg to star in the
movie yeah so Ryan Gosling was
originally gonna be in it but he had hit
an interpretation of the character
sounds like Brando just gained weight in
real life it's sort of that way whereas
Gosling had a character choice and they
were like are you sure it was really a
character choice maybe he just gained
weight was like oh I see this
little heavier heavier no Ryan got no
Ryan Gosling uh spoke out and talked
about that Peter Jackson I talked about
it too but this was because it's pretty
fit yeah yeah it's a really fit guy Ryan
Gosling he went through the hay like 30
pounds for the movie and it got fired
that's I'm sure it's a good journey
though to gain all that weight shirts of
fun
you've never had a name wait for me yes
I guess all that fun in the moment and
not working out that'd be great yeah I
do that for many years the best one on
here like usually the best what movie
though it's the [ __ ] moon I have a
lot of friends for Boston and they're
very they're they're really into sports
cuz you're from New York so I know a lot
of Red Sox fans I mean I don't really
care I'm not like a lot of you know a
lot of New Yorkers or Yankee fans the
characters in he's hiding it's not even
about like no this is a character trait
it's sort of raqqa like a couple ish
like I already remember you're wearing
the Hat that is and they said this shut
down production for four days cuz of it
Wow no I don't care what it it's it's a
movie
I'd wear whatever hat you wanted me to
wear if it's in tune with the character
to some degree it doesn't matter because
it's not even about the characters he's
just hiding his face to me this is this
dude I just think you know way too far
that's funny
Jamie Foxx if you're gonna be dangerous
and somebody got shot I would be scared
to go to that location yeah you're
walking onto they said they had to hire
gangsters to protect them to me I'm like
that doesn't qualify I mean I do I get
why it's on the list but I wouldn't
consider that bad behavior yeah he
uncooperative the possibility of getting
killed and then in your scene where
you're supposed to have a bunch of fake
gunfire - yeah that draws attention to
you that can be bad there are some
horror stories out there of like when
movies portray like certain storylines
about gangsters then
there's being threatened or whatever I
bet there are probably a lot of people
I'm sure people who are mad at him on it
but I bet there's a lot of people were
probably grateful that he did that yeah
because a lot of other people are now no
longer in danger either it was the only
one with that thought right the
production people were probably scared
but then didn't want to get fired so
that's why I didn't say anything but I'm
sure at the end of the day they probably
were like really think I've been in
situations like that it was like a
safety thing do you feel bad about it
but then you're like oh this is my
safety I was yeah I don't want to talk
about on camera but but you have to
always protect your safety I mean when I
was partner short film
those were some serious conditions yeah
your pants ripped or you showed up with
them rips or something yeah it was very
good yeah there's gotta check that out
bad bad safety regulations at YouTube
see I love this on Crispin Glover for
the Charlie's Angels movie if Howard
just thought this trip was so bad it
sounds like such a Crispin Glover thing
to do what's funny to me is they brought
him back from the sequel so they clearly
liked what he did but they replaced him
with his stand-in for Back to the Future
they replaced him who imagine being his
stanzen and getting that chance to just
book a major movie cuz because the guy
you're standing in for is just not that
is unheard of that is the only time I've
heard of that ever happening he must be
a really cool guy get that just oh man
I'm a little bit confusing the Emma
Watson story so she was supposed to have
a scene with Channing Tatum but refused
to do it because he was breakdancing
while in revealing underwear or thought
her so that some leather yeah and she
just wouldn't have it she thought of me
yeah I heard Channing Tatum is like the
nicest guy one of the nicest guys ever
and he's in a married I don't know I
would do a scene with Shannon - Shannon
Tina won't care but would you care if he
was in a leather thong dude I would be
on the Magic Mike set any day I feel
like I gotta see him do that in person
that would be so cool Emma Watson's
career skyrocketed through the Harry
Potter films oh sure were the most
professional sets you could ever been a
part at the same time though they're on
the set of this is the end which is a
whole bunch of vulgar comic actors you
know what you kind of signed up for but
it I mean I guess it is
professional behavior if you're male
flaunting your body like that or maybe
she just liked him you know maybe she
had a thing for Channing - yeah she was
like this is too tempting and not good
for my reputation I can't I can't I
can't do it that's how you theorize yeah
yeah no no no chanting just that hot you
got to walk away I have heard about the
West's snaps ones a couple times there
were things I didn't know about with a
whole superimposing his eyeballs people
were upset that he wasn't brought back
for blade one thing is yeah it's a new
blade whatever you could say all that at
the same time like well everyone has
horror stories if that has played
Trinity experience why would they want
to bring that guy back when clearly he
was so uncooperative on set though I
have to say one of the first movies I
did background on was Brooklyn's Finest
oh and I sat down with Wesley he's the
nicest coolest guy there was no drama I
mean I worked John I worked on
Brooklyn's Finest a few days he's
totally cool I mean he's also friends
with the directors Antoine Fuqua that
was direct directing it was really cool
and just you know in character of being
the the cool guy when I met him on
Brooklyn's Finest he was awesome and he
sat and he talked to me you took
pictures with me nicest guy loved Wesley
Snipes Wow
that is cool you know what changed my
whole opinion yeah how old were you when
you went on this were you an adult I
always probably about 18 popular actor
talking with young attractive actress oh
so you think if I was a guy he wouldn't
be as nice did you see him talking with
any guys I mean I remember real father
Faye Dunaway Faye Dunaway that one stood
out to you that one stood out to me
because I've heard like I forget the
movie she did where she played that
woman that everyone hates and she got a
really bad rap and she stopped getting a
lot of work and some executive told me
you know you got to be really careful
with the roles you play because if you
if you play an evil character people
aren't gonna like they're gonna start
hating you so maybe after that movie
just became obsessed with like not the
evil person I've heard she's very kooky
and real I feel like I've heard
countless crazy stories about fade I
know it's more than just she's difficult
it's just like she's I'm a strange
especially I mean she comes from a
different era too I mean I know like I'm
sure every era presents it's it's weird
obstacles for people growing in this
industry but she had fame at a pretty
young age over the years like this so
like so theatrical
dramatic about everything I mean so most
of the story just make me laugh I guess
the last one that really stood out to me
was the Star Trek one yeah he criticized
the hell out of the screenplay
but it also seemed like he had a really
good intent behind it that I mean he
inhabited the character for so long
through the whole TV show and then all
these movies I mean if you're gonna get
advice from anyone about the passion for
the Star Trek world it's probably best
to get it from that actor and the movie
didn't end up that good but soon think
it could have been worse so thank you
Patrick Stewart well this is a great
list yeah I liked it this is great list
Lauren you could learn a thing or two
about how not to be yeah guys you can
subscribe to the reel rejects click that
notification Bell subscribe to walk
culture more importantly anything you do
with your life you got to check out
Lauren on the social medias or YouTube
channel her Twitter Instagram Facebook
discord its discord I don't even know
what the score was till 20 minutes ago
yeah Napster account her AOL a.m.
account
I would like to shout out a man named
Luke Anderson it's a little back story
with Luke Anderson here Lauren he is not
from California but he has a really
successful job okay
FedEx Manager guides and structs
leadership dad's a pastor him and I were
having these like deep conversations on
patreon back and forth for the longest
time it's been about I want to say like
six months at minimum I haven't heard
back from him I've been chatting him out
every single month can you just say a
couple of sentences maybe if
if a woman asks him for attention he
might give me a attention back again all
right Lucca Anderson I love your name it
just sounds it sounds really really just
good looking something good like a you
know a really good-looking guy
Craig has pitched you really well you
have a good job and come from a good
family if you really love Greg and you
love and you want love from the universe
please do us a favor and reach out just
it just takes one message one DM where
do you like to get your DMS Oh on my my
Yahoo Yahoo inbox
okay got it what's your Yahoo inbox I
don't think I even have access to that
yeah I can't say it on camera it'll get
do you monetize really